super fragt wie kam es zum feature mit
den orsons und wie findest du die und
welche musikrichtung hast du gerne die
erstens haben mich gefragt die haben
dann beat gemacht und in sonnen
geschrieben und habe mich gefragt ob ich
dabei kaputt zu machen und ich finde die
voll cool die uns und wünschte ihnen
auch das dsc noch mehr durchstarten als
die sowieso schon tun und so ist es
entstand nicht selber her auch hip hop
und sohn und so alles was gutes material
girl 100 hat folgenden wunsch beschreibe
seinen ersten kuss in zwei worten
parfüm von der mutter dran bei ihr unter
dem balkon so ich muss ein skater pro
142 hat einen verdacht deine video sind
meistens ungeschnitten und wirken auf
mich teilweise ein bisschen improvisiert
was ich feiere stimmt mein verdacht dass
du deine szenen teilweise aus dem
stegreif aufnimmst immer improvisiert
alle meine videos sind im ruhigen und
ich probiere die auch immer ohne schnitt
zu machen
so gibt nichts geschriebenes bei mir in
den videos bis khalifa 385 möchte wissen
frage an teddy was für eine sportart
machst du gerne warst du mal wenn ich
zeit habe schon lange nicht mehr und ich
laufe gerne von say interessiert hätte
hast du schon angebote von größeren
fernsehsendern bekommen oder wurde die
mitgliedschaft bzw eine gastrolle in
einem film serie angeboten wurde und
abonniert in diesem jahr 32 zdf
produktion für nächstes jahr plant eine
fernsehshow und da passieren dinge und
ich hoffe dass nächstes jahr die
menschen die meine sachen gut finden
auch zu den kosten kommen
mister kobolde frage wie bist du auf
deine ganzen charaktere gekommen
einfach im leben rumlaufen gucken so
jeden tag und man begegnungen und
einfach so dass das das leben hat so
viel zu bieten
einfach mal nach links und nach rechts
gucken dann hast du schon 450 jemand auf
der straße erkennt oder anspricht oder
dumme frage stand die idee zum thema
fall kommt man tätig bestimmte antworten
könnte wie ich damit umgehe
ich freue mich in der regel wenn ich
fragen gestellt bekommen die gerade
nicht so passen dann sage ich immer
passt gerade nichts ist aber in der
regel freue ich mich und wir sehen uns
durch den wald